FEW WEEKS AGO WITH RODRIGUES
WE'RE SET TO
MEIER BLEW AN EDGE TRYING TO
MAKE A TAND ANOTHER LITTLE SHOTE
BACK
LITTLE PAY BACK FROM THE HITTHE,
GUENTZEL UP CENTER SKATING ON
THIS LINS I
HAVE, YOU WERE IN PITTSBURGH FOR
THAT GAME TW
THE --
CHAD RUHWEDEL.
NOW DAHLEN
>> Randy: HERE'S MEIER
KARLSSON
IN FRONT FIRES, AND THEN HE CHES
UP I GOING TO STAY
HERE'S A CHANCE FOR LETANG
SCORHEELS, AND THE SPEED,
COMING
GETS IT TO CARTER. AND GOOD
BACK CHECK BY BONINO TO GET IT D
ONE.POWERS HIS WAY AND THEN TRYG
TO SET UP COUTURE.
COULDN'T PUT IT ON NET
PUCK AVAILABLE AT THE LINE AND
RUHWEDEL WILL L SCREEN
MEIER.
AND BALCERS BATTLE BACK TO ERIK
KARLSSD FOR A LANE AND A
LITTLE TRAFFIC TO GET THERE.E N
PLAYERS SHARKS NEE DROPS FOR COE
WANTS THE PUCK TO GET OFF THE
STICK GO UP HIGH
>> Drew: LET'S GO BACK
BECAUSE IT THE FRESH ICE,
ALL RESTED UP.
>> Drew: READY TO HE WAY
BURNS STUMBLESTSBURGH.
K.
QUART.
AROUND KARLSSON.
.
>> Drew: A LITTLE STUMBL, MY
FRIEND, DAY-TO-DAY OVERALL ON
THE SEASON ON FACEOFF.
THAT WAS TOUGH RIGHT THERE
WITH SOUT OF THE
ZONE,
A BLOCKEES HERE'S JAKE
GUENTZEL BEHINRE PERFECT IN OVEE
HERE AND GET THREE FRESH PLAYERS
ON